thank you
[Music]
so I heard you're a big superhero fan
hate superheroes you know that dude all
right what's your favorite superhero to
hate uh yeah who's the lamest the lamest
who's the wackest that you're like I
can't stand that [ __ ]
you didn't have a favorite one growing
up yes I have Batman Batman was always
been like super cool but now you think
it's whack still but now I'm like dude
it's like are you over it I I turned 10
and I was like yeah I'm done
yeah I turned 10 and that's when I was
like uh it's got this [ __ ] thing
dude what's up with this guy right here
dude everything else [ __ ] you know
died down so the wackest superhero that
I'm just like I don't get it it's
probably uh
uh I know there's one that I was like
who the [ __ ] is this guy
well dude I was gonna say though uh
Marvel like the Marvel Captain Marvel
yeah I don't know what the hell she's
about
I don't know I feel like they they they
made a superhero for us to like and it
was real power the girl powered as a
woman who's the best who's aware of
everyone I'm just like
I feel like you're tricking me to like
this one you're making you're forcing a
powerful person on me and it's like
I still think the Hulk can kick her ass
but you know was there ever a superhero
that had like Mexican representation no
more dude we we just yeah dude that guy
was badass oh I guess that's uh Mayan
right in the more anyways you see that
they're forcing those ones I don't know
dude it's so weird
well uh are you a fan of anybody here a
fan of Henry Cavill Superman I've never
seen that what you don't seem out of
steel I think I've seen it but he's he's
not like
that Superman I don't even remember
spectacular look at Joe look how bored
he is dude
no you know what I was thinking about
what he is checked out so like Street
Fighter did a really good job of like
making cool cultural badass characters
yeah okay because they had the Native
American guy Apple was doing like
[ __ ] Native American dance [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah they had like the [ __ ] like
right flame what's that guy uh
oh [ __ ] yeah what's his name is it the
Indian guy though you know what I mean
like they had all those they did a good
job they did a really good job of like
blending culture
[Laughter]
what are you saying he [ __ ] did it in
school so many times I used to [ __ ]
jump out of the [ __ ] you know the two
layers I just jump off into the turn
[Laughter]
that's what Japan thinks of all the
races yeah that's what's funny I like
how they got Jean-Claude Van Damme as
guile bro oh wow that was fun yeah
All-American man is a Belgian accent I'm
going to kick your ass as so hard
he's the most french guy ever I don't
even know if he's French is he Belgium
basically yeah
recently Henry Cavill Henry Cavill
recently played Superman as the the guy
from Man of Steel and also in Justice
League and Batman versus Superman he's
basically the most recent version of
Superman right he looks like a
[ __ ] Superman and he looks like
a [ __ ]
yeah who's this guy he's got the little
curly kid yeah he's handsome not gay but
he couldn't get it
what had recently happened if anybody's
been following like the DC Universe
stuff and like how they're you know
redoing how everybody acknowledges that
the dcules
I'm [ __ ] relax man relax
for six videos
somehow jacked off in six different
topics
in case you didn't see the first video
or the second video
um so Henry Cavill recently was on
[ __ ] uh social media telling his fans
telling everybody that he's coming back
to play Superman this was a huge thing
he is he was featured in uh The Rock's
Black Adam right in like one of the
later scenes or whatever spoiler dude
yeah
he confirmed it himself on social media
where he talks about like I am coming
back as a man still et cetera Etc right
this was like was that ever a question
though well it's because like uh he
wasn't that franchise wasn't necessarily
for sure gonna go on so when like the
guy comes back on social media and says
he's gonna do it obviously anybody who's
a fan of him as Superman rallies yeah
the Nerds [ __ ] yeah right but also I
think that if you're gonna hire
first of all if you're gonna hire
somebody to be like a superhero they
gotta like this world because this
[ __ ] sucks when they hire somebody
and they don't like like me if that
would have been a superhero and then I
come in for the next you want to do a
sequel I don't [ __ ] know dude I don't
know if I want to he's not in love with
this [ __ ] no no no with this
character
sometimes would be like I love this guy
they're willing to do more videos more
movies like how Ryan Reynolds love
Deadpool and he killed it with Deadpool
even though he had some type of like
love for this and then he's still stuck
it because yeah it sucks as a fan to
like follow this character and they're
just like I don't know dude I really
want to do this oh yeah it sucks to hear
it I'm over here doing blow right now
dude I don't got time for that it's like
that sucks for the Nerds oh no but Iron
Man
this guy is not what you're explaining
so I don't know where you got that but
um this guy does love Superman this guy
does he likes it he's like he likes it
he was excited to confirm that he was
coming back okay never mind everything I
said remember it's not always the
actor's decision for a future superhero
um it's it's not always their decision
though it's not like they can be like I
can't wait for the next production like
you know what I mean it's it's up to the
suits yeah so the thing is he was ready
uh you know there's this whole thing
about like he got [ __ ] teasing Black
Adam they're like he's coming back from
Man of Steel too he confirms it because
the Production Studios talked about it
yeah but then DC does a whole [ __ ]
overhaul Warner Brothers there's a whole
overhaul in the Production Studio James
Gunn becomes the new kind of like Kevin
feige of the DC Universe yeah and once
they uh and the whole point it was
pretty close the whole point is not to
uh do individual shitty movies the whole
point is actually to plan out things oh
like how Marvel did yeah like how Marvel
did they specifically wanted like a
10-year plan like Marvel which means
that now they're replanting suddenly
they don't want Henry Cavill to play
Superman because
exactly they need a new one now that
makes sense you know what they should
get that [ __ ] from Euphoria I
thought he looked like I thought God
[Laughter]
you know you have like dark hairs like
handsome chiseled tall he's 28. yeah I
think he could be getting old dude
character that he played in that movie
is very anti-superman in that sense but
yes it's a good he's not even [ __ ]
America he's like British or some [ __ ]
British so is Henry Cavill yeah he's
[ __ ] British people Ritz
taking our [ __ ] women uh Brunetto
right he can't be blonde yeah yeah
you know why hey what if they pull a
[ __ ] like a Little Mermaid and he's
[ __ ] full-on black
is that bad oh
man some people might be really mad I
think Superman's supposed to be Jewish
no I think so I think Krypton no but I
think part of Krypton
I think I thought he was Kryptonic I
think it's based on a Jewish story
folktale because look like [ __ ] Moses
was like a [ __ ] baby that just oh my
my place you put him in a [ __ ] River
that's like oh the [ __ ] krypton's
getting [ __ ] up so then they bring
them to uh to the Earth [ __ ] right there
shouldn't be a black Superman you broke
my brain it really is it's called uh
it's Shaquille O'Neal oh true it's still
true true true yeah I've never saw steel
you got it tatted on the shoulder too
yeah his shoe logo is this
little dookie squat
uh I don't know dude I wish I cared more
about the superheroes
is there a superhero movie that you were
like I hate superhero movies but this
one I actually like the new Batman movie
Nirvana songs I'm like [ __ ] they just
[ __ ] they make
so dude that one dude that movie was a
double spit
that was a great take I like that Batman
the Penguin and everything was so
[ __ ] Colin Farrell did kill you like
Dark Knight or no uh I actually did like
Dark Knight but I like that recent
battle so basically you're like the
world that he was in but that world that
he was in was again was like the recent
one never fell out of it I never fell
out of it like oh it's just a movie it
just felt like this was a dope ass world
I was I was in their world and by the
end of the movie I came back to my world
oh [ __ ] I was there bro I love that and
never took me out like that's a little
too much it's too little George Clooney
one you like that one dude that's my
favorite one don't you start talking
[ __ ] about that one was [ __ ] those
movies I don't know what you're talking
about all right dude don't even talk
about the seal song that's SEAL song
I don't like superhero movies and he's
like he knows every [ __ ] Batman I
know and like if I like Batman I guess
all right besides Batman
besides Batman actually I like Batman do
you like Logan that was kind of dark I
don't like Logan did you watch it
because again I was like these other
ones it's like I think that's something
I for me it was like oh that's that's
for the white people bro like I don't
know like Thor all that I'm just like
I'm over it more of uh you like
superhero movies where the hero isn't
necessarily super it's like an anti-hero
yeah because that's what it sounds like
because Batman doesn't have like Batman
he doesn't have any powers you don't
like Nacho Libre yeah I love Nacho Libre
dude that guy's a [ __ ] here
I mean that's a good superhero movie
because I think you just open up a door
in my mind right now yeah maybe it's the
ability thing Batman is like me like he
doesn't believe in himself he's kind of
like no I just I do my own thing and
whatever
he's very Twilight yeah like he hides
his face don't look at me man yeah yeah
I do it I just do it help people but
don't look at me man you know he's
hiding he's mysterious that's me
that's me I'm like that I don't like I
don't like a lot of attention but I do
but then I don't I helping people I like
[ __ ] don't girls that don't like me
back yeah I'm Batman baby
Superman's not relatable to you oh no
yeah because he's too ideal yeah dude
he's not really Superman's too perfect
that's in a toxic relationship with
Catwoman they fighting [ __ ] playing
and all this [ __ ] Superman's a [ __ ]
dude he can't be he doesn't like being
himself yes Superman is like super nerdy
he's like afraid of like can you just
talk to the girl it's a hard sell as
time goes I think it's harder and harder
to sell so it's true he rep he really
represents the ideal yeah apparently
yeah he's a cook he's a cook right
because he's the girl's looking getting
hit on at the office hey [ __ ] what's
your name Mary Lou Mary Jane Mary Lou
Lois Lane Lois Lane I don't think so hey
Louis nice [ __ ] tits in the book and
he's like oh he says walking he's
watching this at the like oh you're just
gonna let yourself talk to like that
he's [ __ ] cool it's like the biggest
dick in the office relax it's cool and
then what makes him weak is Rock
he's afraid rocks make him weak that's
what goes to one of those [ __ ] hippie
ass hippie ass girl stores and then he's
like crystals yeah yeah he gets he dates
a [ __ ] hipster chick and [ __ ] him up
he can't be here the [ __ ] is wrong with
you he's Christmas it's just amethyst
you're a bad energy
to sell them yeah do some I don't like
Spider-Man either he just seems he's a
little [ __ ]
Spiderman which one all three of them
yeah look at how he's like Mary Jane
don't like me unless I'm Spider-Man yeah
they're all like that he's literally in
Heights I don't like that [ __ ] that's
why nerds just love him I feel the same
way from Spider-Man without the powers
they're like the only way I could get a
girls if I catfish them see that's all
they're doing they're always in Disguise
yeah mysterious it's a bad example for
these young kids they're like the only
way is when when I pretend to be someone
else then they love me some whack-ass
[ __ ] yeah dude young kids come off here
nerd dude I'm telling you there's a girl
nerd Who's down to do some wild [ __ ] but
I've been in bad bad class you know what
I mean those [ __ ] nerds just as wild
Yep they're into [ __ ] weird [ __ ] but
hey they're down to [ __ ] I mean you guys
could don't both [ __ ] and watch weird
[ __ ] together dude come on yeah dude
there's hope yeah dude that is the
generation now a lot of people like just
get together and watch anime and go [ __ ]
right the [ __ ] eat their cheese puffs
and [ __ ]
like cheese puffs for some reason this
is like a cheeseburger you don't like
cheese puffs I do but then you're like
all right after three like all right
what am I ten it's an odd stuff that's
enough it's all over the place it's
messy the cheese it's like dissolves in
your mouth it's weird I'm over it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]